have you guys ever experienced what
thirst is not having to drink a single
drop of water for days these people have
our fridges are full of water please
give whatever you can for the sake of
allah so they can have something to
drink
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah guys
this video is about enhan oma i've been
meaning to do this video the year before
the previous year because every year
when it's a pride month um she comes out
with a outmost support now i want to
make some disclaimers here nobody's
asking for anybody in any community to
be harmed nobody's saying that nobody's
saying that they shouldn't exist et
cetera we hate the sin okay we hate the
sin and if someone persists on the sin
we hate the scenery as well but in this
instance most of the games we hate the
sin until we establish to ourselves who
the person is and what's he about and
he's promoting it now what's really
funny is that you have these sellouts
these people who are who would rather
please the creation rather than the
creator and literally that they go far
and beyond yeah the lgbtq community
screams this much and you've got these
sellouts that scream that much you know
and her her her faith her being the
muslim there's a big question mark i'm
not doing
there's a massive question mark for
somebody to go and propagate something
where allah subhanahu wa in the quran
has said that he's destroyed nations
he's destroyed them warning warning that
he destroyed them and allah we believe
it's a sin i've spoken to people in
speaker's corner who have these
tendencies i'm speaking to them i have
civilized discussions with them i never
want ill for them or i want them to be
harmed so let's not go to extremes
mohammadi jab got in contact with ilan
omar and made the tweet did she reply no
and she is out there outright
supporting
can you imagine these people if i went
to the lgbt community and i told them
can you guys please vocally say we
support the sharia
do you think they would
no they would say no we're not because
we don't believe in it okay i'm not
going to blame them i'm not going to say
you're bad or even that's your opinion
that's you don't have to then why is it
that people like herself have to go out
her way let me tell you why guys like
the prophet salallahu sallam said yeah
in bukhari
or muslim
that you will follow the previous
nations handspan by handspan
literally every little inch if they go
into eliza's hole you will follow them
there
and he said are you talking about the
people of the book he said who else
now we know the people of the book have
sadly diverted their ways you know and
you can see that even some of them are
pro lgbqt and some of them are going
their way and if you look at omar you
can see that literally just to please
these group of people and if you think
about it when you go to these kind of
places of being an mp you know we've got
one here you know uh i've got his name
we've got an mp here when you follow
their ways you need to understand up
there you need to show your loyalty
they're going to say to you online is
messenger or our liberal values you're
going to have to say if you say allah
this messenger they're going to say bye
bye
allah see you later
but if you say liberalism they'll say
okay come calm now we open you with arms
even they have conditions
and look at the lgbqt and the the lobby
yeah look at them you accept it you're
good come dance with us hold hands whoa
let's see the moment she comes and says
you know what actually this is a sin
you're finished see you later bye bye
and guess what these people are wrapping
on this inside i want to keep this much
longer guess what these people are never
going to be happy with you
they are never going to be happy with
you never they've been down they'll have
you helping their course do you think
like how does these big companies really
support the lgb qt movement no
they're saying is that where money is to
be made we support it if the sharia
comes to be in a country for example if
you can't become a muslim country adidas
nike and all these companies are going
to go in line with the values because
they're consumer bases do they're
muslims
all i'm seeing is this
these people are never going to be happy
with you and on the day of judgment omar
online this message i'm not going to be
happy with you you're going to lose this
life and the hereafter there is a big
question mark on you massive and anyone
that supports you
may allah guide them anybody that's
supporting me like item i don't know how
a scholar hasn't come and give a fatwa
of your disbelief like
i'm not doing it it's not my place but
i'm surprised how a scholar hasn't come
and declared you a disbeliever i'm
surprised once again i can't do to
create review it's not my place i'm just
saying there's a massive question mark
on you yeah massive question mark and
we'll speak the hack yes we would wait
we'll see if you're going to change the
way they say no you're not big question
mark on you and anyone that follows you
and supports you yeah may allah
subhanahu wa you
of you
her and guide us but it's our duty to
warn you against these people inshallah
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh